all right we might be seeing another
nims oh I'm liking it enough to play it
again will white respond with the night
here yes they will okay so we don't have
instead of night here Bishop to g5 but
rather more well more just right to it
this should look very familiar I've run
with this set up quite a bit ly 5d6
structure and now this square is where I
want to be hop to it night right here
stop this Bishop move let's stop this
pond move if the night place here and
the bishop takes I might want to
consider what we might want to consider
hmm pawn takes like this and then
getting this night to this square but i
think this pond could be in some trouble
thinking for a second about h5 h4
anticipating night g3 let's see about
that though hmm yeah I don't want to
bring my night here I come over in this
direction this pond isn't gonna push
this Bishop isn't gonna be a bother is
it I want to come over here get to f4
since this Bishop isn't around a guard
f4 it's not really a bother here is it
all right let's go night I don't want to
go to see five no thanks let's go night
castle maybe I could get back to this
square if this bishop wants to come over
here maybe I could come back over here
it's castle all right well I better take
care wise i'm getting a squashed okay
yeah I have a really clear plan right
now and it's to get rid of these nights
and then reposition my night on e5 two
ways I could get there my first thought
was to play here I could play here
though too there's no reason not to just
do that right my bishop can't be
deflected from its defense so let's play
here it's more aggressive and I just
want to sit on the e5 square I want to
hold that down there might however be
something with c5 and then if i take
night place here like so well it's not
now because I have pressure on the
bishop it's something with c5 takes
takes just to undermine my Knights
position I might need to just play f6
and to compensate for the weaknesses
that I create with f6 I might want to
have my bishops it on f7 just as you
would in a something kettle type of
position right you do this move you
weaken these two you place the bishop
here to watch over these two squares so
similarly if I do this to reinforce the
night i weakened these two maybe my
bishop could play here and watch all
over both anyhow I really do feel like
f6 is best right now or maybe not maybe
queen here is better clean trade and
then play here
doubled pawns are not really a problem
but I actually queen here oh you know
what Queen here no it's not really
working is it or maybe it is a little
calculation needed right now Queen g5 if
the Queen exchange is avoided with let's
say Queen f2 I could be taking here and
if Bishop back to see one to hit my
queen I think I come back maintain this
pin and then I come back with my bishop
a little bit later I think I'm gonna try
that hmm I'm gonna go with Queen g5
shoot up a lot of time here so the
Queen's you to come off or I went upon
i'm pretty sure also okay well let's uh
let me do this and the last thing I was
going to say is even if my night is
taken the position then transitions
position transitions into what it
transitions into a good versus bad
bishop I want to stop this pond from
playing here I don't want the a file to
open up if Bishop takes how do I
recapture I'm pretty sure like this
bishop here might already be forcing
Bishop takes Knight let me do this
pressure on this pond it's hit twice
okay now we're seeing a classic example
of good versus bad bishop now in this
resulting in game I think I might want
to keep a look around so just to maybe
still cause some trouble and maybe get
my bishop on this square put pressure on
this pond and make it inconvenient
somehow me or maybe position my rook on
f4 and if it's captured that I think
this is the right idea look right here I
think is an important move if it's taken
I could capture like this and then get
my king to this square pressure on this
pond
and having these as targets I think work
out well i think if i trade rooks with
rope takes rook it turns out to be a
drop let's see if I'm right about that
let's see okay pawn here no actually I
could just win this pond now I was I was
threatening this pond so now this is
definitely a one game because I'm
snipping this pawn stayed come with a
threat rook takes pawn yeah this has to
be correct now I'm just taking this pawn
if it's threatened I'll come back over
if the King plays here I could do this
if there a place to f6 I get up here
just in time although the rook and maybe
play to e6 mmm that could be a bit
disruptive but no no no no no no no I'm
on the bishop right now hang on
recognize the direct threats first
instead of getting caught up into your
little plans here so I think I just come
back over rook here is probably good too
but I'm okay with just playing here
connected passed pawn and let's defend
here and watch out for the King getting
to this square ok King position King
position right here this is connected
passed pawn I want my king here I think
okay let's stop the King from getting
active and I want to weasel my bishop
around now pinpointing this zigzagging
my way okay I'm on this the bishop has
to come back I could be taking this
square but I like the Ponca push here
but I could Zig I can still zigzagging
right here maybe that could have been
prevented but now I'm getting really
active and that's close to me and now
that pond is going to be one I think
maybe this is the best try but now
that's losing to some stuff so this is
again good versus bad bishop ending and
now this pond is ready to rumble
there I cannot be stopped all right if
Bishop played there I would have just
taken right so these are these are
falling down and then the bishops lost
okay all right good game Tim let's back
up here flip that board and see what the
story is I don't know about the the
immediate pond push so I would hold off
on this pawn push not so sure about it
it does stop a night maneuver c6a five
but something seems something seems
weird with running with d5 so early on
so that's that's one thing it's a has my
attention because now I have this square
available I could already say this early
on c5 is a possibility for my night
whenever there's a weakness is created
very early on I definitely start to come
back to those particular positions in
question getting into that type of
situation so early on so something other
than d5 might include nitey 2nite g3 f3
again I have seen this setup with 92 f
three and then like a g4 night g3 which
has given me problems I've had a in
blitz I believe at least one GM went
with that setup and I've seen some im's
I believe as well something something
with that I'm not certain of the exact
move order but something along the lines
of the f3 g4 structure with the white
pawns and the night coming behind it
with g3 and maybe even throwing up the
age pun so be aware about that type of
structure that you could maybe test out
to play around with out
to be honest I'm feeling pretty
comfortable as soon as I I made up this
decision to not play here but rather
just come over in this direction
Bishop's kind of out of play and I'm
eyeing the f4 square trade of nights I
hold on to the e5 square and this is a
stronghold this is really tough now
Queens are off this is this is difficult
for you to break down I don't know if
that there is a way to break it down so
I think it's getting all the way back
once again to pawn structure the d5 move
run with something else 92 f 39 g3 stuff
ok